welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Spider-Man across the
spider-verse just revealed a butt ton of
new spider people in its official poster
even more in wider International posters
some of them shown in last week's
trailer but even more new exciting
crossovers that bridge this spider-verse
from animated series to live action even
I spotted 40 Spider-Man in this poster
and I'm gonna break them all down and
organize them into tears of the core
group some fun inclusions designed to
Delight fans and then just some other
random weirdos also who is missing from
this movie and why and thanks to Rocket
money for sponsoring today's video more
about them later let's start by merging
the vertically oriented domestic poster
with the international posters just to
get one giant picture to work off of
nice thank you okay started in the
middle that of course is Miles Morales
upside down while all the other spider
people are right side up showing his
Outsider status among Miguel O'Hara's
spider Force also notice that miles's
suit is shredded with claw marks likely
given to him by Miguel O'Hara's sharp
sharp claws yeah okay so the core spider
people in this movie include Miguel
O'Hara Spider-Man 2099 from Nuevo York
voiced by Oscar Isaac a likely
antagonist in this movie he's here to
miles left and then to miles is right is
Gwen Stacy Haley Steinfeld from earth65
who has been inducted at the spider
force and gotten close with spider Punk
Hobie Brown Daniel kaluya directly above
her on the poster from Earth 138 bitten
by a spider radiated by a legal waste
dumping and becomes a punk rocker from
Camden it's actually his Chuck Taylor's
that Gwen now wears now to the right of
them is Peter B Parker Jake Johnson now
wearing his coat and his Baby Bjorn as
he has gotten back together with MJ and
produced a daughter named Mayday Parker
now to the lower right of Gwen is
pavitar prabhakar that's the Indian
Spider-Man from ambaton in Earth 50101
the Spider-Man I think I'm most excited
for in this movie then sliding over to
Miguel's that is Spider-Woman Jessica
Drew voiced by Issa Ray a major mentor
to Gwen and she will be pregnant in this
movie Lord Miller said that her
character is based on the run-up to the
secret Wars comic event right in front
of Jessica Drew is Ben Reilly the
Scarlet Spider known for his pale blue
hoodie with the sleeves cut off he is
actually a clone of Peter Burgers from
the clone saga okay so those are the
major figures that seem to be in Miles
orbit in this movie but this poster just
revealed some major new cameos on the
bottom right that is the teenage
Spectacular Spider-Man from the 2008
animated series when he was voiced by
Josh Keaton it's so cool that he's in
this movie and yes it was confirmed by
Chris Miller it's the right of him that
is an older Spider-Man known as the high
collar the glasses the jacket this is
Ezekiel Sims from The Last Stand run you
might have seen some fan art of Toby
Maguire in that Ezekiel Sims jacket and
to the right of him that is spider wolf
from Earth 7085 we saw this werewolf in
the Nexus Hub in the trailer and by a
werewolf Spider-Man no I'm not referring
to Andrew Garfield there's also this
Spider-Man in a three-piece business
suit we saw him in the trailer as well
as Spider-Man Unlimited from the late
90s animated series directly to the
right of Peter B Parker we also saw him
in the trailer with his Webby Cape as he
chased miles to the right of the
business suit is Mabel Parker lady
spider from Earth 803 a steampunk era
spider totem who also appears in the
trailer she has the Waldo arms that prop
up her laptop now behind Mabel I might
be crazy but doesn't that look like a
spider Hulk now Sony wouldn't have the
rights to Hulk so it might just be a
super small green Spider-Man it never
gets named behind him looks like a
spider wizard you shall not have great
power without great responsibility now
right behind Peter B Parker to the right
of him is a silver armored Spider-Man
pretty sure this is the spider armor
Mark 1. to the right of him is a
Spider-Man with blonde hair poking at
the top of his mask wearing a
Letterman's jacket I think this is Flash
Thompson Spider-Man and we saw a mile
slide under his legs in the trailer now
right behind Obi Brown to the left there
is that hooded I want to say Russian
Spider Woman that Miles jumps over in
the trailer and nearly touches her booty
but beneath her above Gwen into the left
of Hobie is Margo spider bite Earth
22191 she's one who uses a virtual
Avatar and fights crime in cyberspace to
the upper right of Hobie is the sun
spider Charlotte Weber she is
ehlers-danlos syndrome that affects her
joints and connective tissue so she uses
a wheelchair and crutches to the right
of her is cyborg Spider Woman who's
actually revealed to be in this movie as
part of a puzzle now ever since the
first sequel announcement with the
shifting art styles in October 2019 we
all have been looking forward to the
Japanese supaida band takuya Yamashiro
from Earth 51778 the 1978 Japanese live
action series The Emissary from hell I
could be wrong but I think we actually
see him in the murky upper right there
are two Spider-Man with differently
shaped eyes that I think might be takuya
now it's easy to say you want us save
money but unless you're one of those
old-timey Bankers with a green visor and
the clickety-clack Machine it can feel
pretty hard to do that's why I like
rocking money it makes saving money feel
easy rocket money is my favorite
all-in-one finance app it helps me
manage my expenses and save hundreds one
of Rocket money's best features is that
it helps you find and cancel all your
unwanted subscriptions with this app I
discovered I was wasting hundreds or
thousands every month on stuff that I
didn't really even use with the money I
have saved from canceling those
subscriptions I freed up lots of money
for traveling to see my family over the
holidays or you know traveling back home
to decompress after seeing my family for
the holidays I also love rocket money
smart savings account and their budget
tool with a smart savings account you
can choose the amount you want to save
and how frequently rocket money will
automatically deposit your money into a
savings fund that you can withdraw from
any time and with a budgeting tool you
can automatically monitor your spending
by category get notifications whenever
you exceeded your spending limits and
visualize your spend to earn ratio by
month quarter or year and if you're
really feeling ambitious rocket money
can negotiate your bills for you from
internet service bills to cable and
phone bills simply upload a photo of
your bill and Rocket money does rest you
can unlock even more features in Premium
Too once you've signed up 3.4 million
people use rocket bunny to save with
just a few simple Taps you can be one of
them if you want to start managing your
finances the easy way you need this app
try rocket money out for free and
support our Channel head to
rocketmoney.com or click the link in the
video description okay let's ship to the
lower left corner of the poster there we
see Mary Jane spinnerette Earth 18119
from the renew your valve storyline we
also know that her daughter Anna May
Parker spider-ling will also appear in
this movie to the left of her is the PS4
Insomniac Spiderman with the white logo
everyone loves ham and then to the upper
right of spinnerette is doppelganger
that's the vicious six-arms Spider-Man
created by Vegas after infinity War
looks like Carnage but it's really his
own thing he does team up with Carnage
though now above Jessica Drew is Julia
Carpenter Spider Woman and then to the
right of Jessica looks like the spider
armor Mark III from the ends of the
Earth storyline to the left of Jessica
is the bombastic Bag Man we saw him in
the trailer this is when Peter has to
wear a bag on his head after he gets
detached from the Symbiote in the Baxter
building normally wears a fantastic poor
suit but since Sony doesn't have the
rice in the Fantastic Four they put him
in a spider suit now behind PS4
Spider-Man is another spider thing in a
suit looks like a medieval Knight of
some kind and then a Mexican
revolutionary that I'm really excited to
get to know more behind doppelganger
that might be arachnido junior between
him and bombastic Bag Man is that thick
Spider-Man with the yellow icon the one
we see seated in the trailer now above
bombastic Pac-Man is a cowboy Spider-Man
who Jessica Clements says looks like
Patrick O'Hara web Slinger from the
Ultimate Spider-Man animated series you
know what I think she's right right
behind him I'm pretty sure that spider
cat from earth99 and then behind and to
the right of spider cat there is one
with huge eyes and I wonder if that
could be the Ultimate Spider-Man and
then to the upper left of spider cat
that might be the Lego Spider-Man
because that does look like it has more
of a blocky shape to it now we also know
from the trailer that auto Octavius
superior Spider-Man and Spider armor
Mark II spider cop spider monkey and
manga Peter Parker will be part of this
movie I just couldn't find them in the
poster but I will end on perhaps the
most exciting ones are live actually
Peter Parker's because in the far upper
left corner of the Turkish subconscious
Spider-Man poster is a Spider-Man with a
gold emblem on his chest that looks a
lot like the integrated suit from the
third Act of Spider-Man no way home and
then in the far upper left corner of the
Chinese poster there is a tall lanky
Spider-Man with huge eyepieces and a
massive chest emblem does this not look
like the Andrew Garfield Amazing
Spider-Man suit I mean it's almost
guaranteed at this point that we're
gonna give vocal cameos by Tom Holland
and Andrew Garfield maybe even Toby
McGuire in this movie as well right but
there you have it 40 spider people
identified on these posters and yes that
does not include spider ham Spider-Man
Noir and Penny Parker maybe because
they're dead you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at EA boss follow
new Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars
for more our analysis of everything you
love thanks for watching bye
[Music]